oui michel piccoli bonsoir cette
dernière image c'est vraiment celle de
la jalousie j'espère pour vous que le
personnage à d'autres facettes plus
enthousiaste plus oui bien sûr c'est
même la première image puis on peut dire
du personnage enfin la pièce commence
dans le bonheur le plus complet
apparemment et le délire le gouffre
arrive mais ça provoque que tout un tas
de choses fantastiques c'est une pièce
tout à fait fantastique sur la jalousie
sur l'amour fou sur la rédemption sur le
temps on pourrait même dire que c'est
une pièce sur le temps qui le temps
guérit toutes les plaies toutes les
misères et puis il ya une chose
extraordinaire je suis expire c'est que
chaque fois dans les moments les plus
tragiques parce que c'est une farce
aussi cette pièce j'expire adore la
farce dans le tragique à chaque moment
il ya le personnage qui s'arrête et qui
dit au public vous savez je joue la
comédie
c'est du théâtre je suis acteur mais
s'amuse shakespeare lui-même s'amuse
avec ses folies c'est ce qui est
admirable
c'est la première fois que vous
interprétez shakespeare je crois oui
c'est la première fois qu'on peut dire
que 88 sera pour vous l'année
shakespeare parce que bon vous voilà
dans le conte d'hiver et puis ensuite à
avignon avec hamlet
oui j'ai j'ai de la chance de d'être
couronné au roi des comédiens dans la
mise en scène de chéreau d'hamlet
et puis après je vais encore continuer à
nanterre avec une pièce de koltès qui a
d'ailleurs adapté la le conte d'hiver de
shakespeare
cette fois ci sous la direction de de
chéreau et avec aux événements la reine
du boulevard qui vient jouer chez nous
chez nous juste une ferme de 10 et je ne
suis pas chez moi m'a fait comme je suis
sociétaire morale dans ce théâtre je
peux dire chez nous s'expire c'est un
passage obligé pour les grands comédiens
comme vous un michel piccoli
or obligé non il ya beaucoup de grands
acteurs qui n'ont jamais joué
shakespeare mais il faut pas prendre
shakespeare comme une décoration
il faut prendre ça comme une découverte
comme une recherche comme une aventure
merveilleuse heureux de retrouver but
logique avec laquelle vous n'aviez pas
joué depuis deux ans je crois depuis
quatre ans il ya quatre ans nous avons
joué terre étrange est toujours sous la
direction de luc bondy et
on fait le film d'ailleurs terre
étrangère qui doit passer à la
télévision
une question annexe est d'ailleurs la
dernière michel piccoli on est très
heureux de vous recevoir ce soir mais
vous n'êtes pas très tendre avec la
télévision entre nous n'allez pas un peu
fort et un peu loin quand vous dites que
la télé c'est le le sida mental je n'ai
entendu à la radio
récemment oui là j'ai repris une phrase
dame rayonnages célèbre et j'ai
peut-être eu tort de le dire mais par
rapport à une autre
une citation concernant un autre
événement mais si vous dites que je vais
fort avec la télévision je peux vous
répondre mais c'est la télévision qui va
fort avec moi ah bon pourquoi on vous
voit la télévision a mais je ne fais
aucun reproche c'est ça je me permets de
parler de la télévision parce que j'ai
fait beaucoup de télévision j'en fais
encore et j'en ferai toujours je pense
mais je trouve que la télévision est
devenue une guerre fantastique
je suis absolument pour la privatisation
je suis pour la fonction publique des ja
je suis dans ce théâtre dans le décor de
pelosi
je suis dans un dans un lieu de fonction
publique et je m'en réjouis
il faut pas oublier d'ailleurs que avant
80 les radios les télévisions ne pouvait
pas être libre c'était une interdiction
d'état fantastique fort heureusement
elles sont devenues libres et maintenant
cette liberté a disparu c'est dire que
la devil télévision est devenue la proie
de l'argent pourquoi on prévient aussi
on crée on crée à la télévision regard
des faibles en début de semaine oui
c'était sur antenne 2 en début de
semaine mais les spectateurs c'est bien
sûr mais c'est le début de l'année après
celle de l'année vous comprenez nos
fêtes c'est admirable ya apostrophe ce
soir sur antenne 2 6 mettra apostrophe
un peuple apostrophe le pivot est
l'exemple même de ce que peut être la
télévision vous comprenez mais à côté de
ce crime cité oui on peut continuer
comme ça je peux pas vous donner toute
la liste continue on va essayer de
constater très heureux de passer à
antenne 2 parce que si j'étais sur tf1
je sois obligé de vous dire à partir du
8 mars au théâtre des amandiers nanterre
une pièce de william shakespeare le
conte d'hiver mise en scène par luc
bondy à partir du 8 mars au théâtre de
nanterre le congrès a dit on arrête là
mais c'est que c'est très très content
car ne voit ça coûterait trop d'argent
au théâtre on ne peut pas merci michel
piccoli on vous retrouve donc au théâtre
des amandiers de nanterre je le dis
quand même un voyez le
mars prochain voilà merci on croise les
doigts pour vous à vous merci merci au
revoir